>> Sean: FOLLOWING FRIDAY
SPECIAL COUNSEL INDICTMENT, THE
LIBERAL MAINSTREAM DESTROY TRUMP
MEDIA WENT OUT OF THEIR WAY TO
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT, AS THEY
USUALLY DO.
IT CASTS AN OMINOUS SHADOW OVER
THE FUTURE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, DOOM, GLOOM,
HYSTERIA DAILY.
THEY'VE BEEN WRONG THE WHOLE
TIME.
>> IT'S NOW OBVIOUS THAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE TRYING TO
INTERFERE IN OUR ELECTION.
>> IT APPEARS THE STRESS MIGHT
BE GETTING TO HIM.
>> THIS IS GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO THE TRUMP INNER
CIRCLE.
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE STAFF
GETTING MORE AND MORE WORRIED
ABOUT THAT?
OR IS IT JUST DONALD TRUMP
FREAKING OUT ALONE?
>> IT MIGHT JUST BE DONALD TRUMP
FREAKING OUT ALONE, BUT HIS
STAFF HAS TO BE FREAKING OUT
ABOUT HIS FREAK OUT.
>> THE BIG STUFF IS PROBABLY YOU
HAVE TO COME.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH MULLER IS
BEGINNING TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK.
>> DONALD TRUMP SEEMS TO BE MORE
EXCEPT ABOUT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND WHAT CAME OUT
FROM THAT THIS SATURDAY MORNING
THEN THESE KIDS WHO WERE SHOT.
WE GO I THINK TRUMP'S GOT SOME
PROBLEMS.
I DON'T THINK MUELLER WOULDN'T
HAVE TAKEN THE CASE IF HE DIDN'T
SEE A SERIOUS PROBLEM HERE.
>> Sean: SOME OF THE DUMBEST
PEOPLE WORK IN THIS PROFESSION.
MICHELLE MALKIN IS HERE.
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON PAID FOR
RUSSIAN AND RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
LIES TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO LEAD US TO THE
ELECTION.
IT WASN'T VERIFIED.
IT WAS USED TO GET A FISA
WARRANT BECAUSE THEY NEVER TOLD
THE JUDGE THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE THE BARACK OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, PUTIN OPERATIVES
INVOLVED IN MONEY LAUNDERING,
EXTORTION, KICKBACKS, AND
BRIBERY.
THEY GOT 20% OF AMERICA'S
URANIUM.
NOBODY IN THE MEDIA IS TELLING
THEIR VIEWERS ABOUT THESE
IMPORTANT THINGS.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO KICKING AND
SCREAMING LIKE TODDLERS AND A
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO D
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO N
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO Y
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO T
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO E
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO U
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO H
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO T
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO A
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO Y
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO U
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO A
TANTRUM AS LONG AS THEY CAN TO E
REPORTING NIGHTLY, SEAN.
THE REACTION AND RESPONSE THAT
YOU HAVE SHOWN IN THE WAKE OF
THIS UNDERWHELMING INDICTMENT ON
FRIDAY SHOW THAT THOUGH MUCH OF
THE OPPOSITION MEDIA IS PART OF
THEIR OWN 4H CLUB.
HYPERBOLE, HYPERVENTILATION, AND
ALSO HYPOCRISY.
WHEN THEY ARE PLAIN AND OBVIOUS,
NEON SPLASHING SIGNS AND
EVIDENCE OF FOREIGN MEDDLING AND
CORRUPTION, NOT JUST A URANIUM
ONE DEAL, BUT SO MANY OTHERS
OVER THE STRETCH OF BOTH
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THIS 4H CLUB OF THE OPPOSITION
MEDIA HAS BEEN NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE HERE.
THESE WERE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
LOOK TO THE OTHER WAY AT WALTER
DURANTY AND THE CLEAR AND
CONVINCING AND OVERWHELMING
INFILTRATION OF COMMUNIST AGENTS
DURING THE ROOSEVELT
ADMINISTRATION.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO LOOK THE
OTHER WAY AT SAUDI AND CHINESE
AND MEXICAN MEDDLING IN OUR
ELECTION.
THE IDEA THAT THEY CARE NOW AND
ARE TOUTING THIS INDICTMENT AS
SOMEHOW ON THE ORDER OF 9/11 OR
PEARL HARBOR, AS SOME OF THESE
MORE HYSTERICAL JOURNALISTS HAVE
DONE, PLEASE.
THEIR HYPOCRISY IS SHOWING, AND
IS THE TRUE COLORS OF THIS
MEDIA.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT FOREIGN
MEDDLING.
THEY CARE ABOUT BRINGING DOWN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT THAT.
NO ONE UNDERSTOOD ABOUT MUELLER.
ONE GUY IN THE WORLD, JULIANA
SOUNDS, HE KNOW WHERE HE GOT HIS
INFORMATION FROM.
IN TERMS OF THE DNC, IF THEY
WANTED TO FIND OUT THE LEAK AND
WEAR IT THAT, THEY WOULD ASK
HIM.
TO THE GUY, THAT'S NEVER
HAPPENED.
WHAT I SEE ABOUT MUELLER, IS
HERE YOU HAVE ALL OF THIS OTHER
EVIDENCE.
MUELLER WAS THE FBI DIRECTOR
WHEN WE HAD AN INFORMANT INSIDE
OF THE ACTUAL OPERATION OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA IS
ACTING ALL SURPRISED AND
FEIGNING SUCH MORAL OUTRAGE, IT
IS JUST ONE HUGE MASSIVE LIE.
IT'S NOT TRUE, MICHELLE.
HE GOT 20% OF OUR URANIUM.
HOW STUPID ARE WE THAT HE GOT
20% OF OUR URANIUM?
WE HANDED IT TO HIM, AND WE KNEW
THESE CRIMES WERE COMMITTED ON
OUR SOIL AND THEY DID NOTHING.
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
2009, I CAME OUT WITH A BOOK
CALLED "CULTURE OF CORRUPTION,"
AND I POINTED TO ALL THE WAYS IN
WHICH CHICAGO AND THE POTOMAC
AND THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WERE ENDANGERING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY, OUR PUBLIC SAFETY,
EVERY LAST PILLAR OF CIVIL ORDER
IN OUR COUNTRY.
I FEEL SOMEWHAT VINDICATED, BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO CHEER ABOUT IT.
THE DEEP STATE HAS POSED THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF THREAT TO THE
FABRIC OF OUR NATION, AND WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T NEED 13 RUSSIAN
TROLLS TO SO THAT DIVISION AND
CHAOS.
SO MUCH OF IT OF COURSE HAS BEEN
ADVANCED, NOT JUST BY THE OBAMA
OPERATIVES THAT REMAIN IN THE
DEEP STATE, FOR GOODNESS SAKE,
CLINTON AND CARTER ERA BARNACLES
ARE STILL IN THAT DEEP STATE AND
FOGGY BOTTOM AND EMBEDDED IN ALL
OF THAT INTELLIGENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THE BIGGEST SEWERS OF DIVISION
WITHIN AMERICAN SOIL ARE THE
OPERATIVES OF THE SO-CALLED
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
>> Sean: SO CORRUPT.
IT'S ALL BOOMER RINGING BACK.